what an epic show no I wish I could have
watched it
was it seemed like it was great let's
start with the the big news at the top
the king and queen of England I couldn't
surprise I have a surprise
[Music]
[Applause]
because I just wanted to check
um how much how long you'll be using
this room for
we have to give the room up
thank you so much for coming I mean no
big deal I have to tell you I was
driving in and my phone rings as
executive producer and she says well
we've got some news I thought maybe a
contestant something happened she said
well the king and the queen are gonna
make an appearance I said this is so
great how well I don't know they're just
gonna figure it out when Lionel and
Katie are in some room in Windsor Castle
so apparently um Lionel and Katie are
staying overnight they're like I don't
know what's going on like they've got
they've got separate Wings live there
now yeah it's kind of I mean guys please
you know do you miss them do you miss
Lionel and Kate well we've missed them
but we have fun tonight I mean having
had an Atlantis
you know you look at alanis's songs
um those lyrics are so incredible that
the Timeless right I mean I remember
playing those songs on the radio when I
first started and Ed Sheeran what a week
right here he is releasing his album
he's got his door just kicked off and we
had him all night so very good he's like
around he's popping around La doing
these shows on Starline tours I passed
the big line coming in I was I thought
it was a shop a sale I thought oh
there's a sale he turns out was Ed
Sheeran on a bus
I love it all right so what can we look
forward to next week because now we have
next week's fun next week's Disney night
next week we'll have Sophia Carson
helping us out big costuming big
performances big numbers uh all the
glitz and glamor in front of Disney and
a little acting from the judges of
myself
a little bit come on I'm trying to be
discovered you know what you're going to
be in the next live action right the
next Disney film um Hello Mickey Minnie
you guys Luke really did love holding
down the fort I felt like
I felt like Luke was at home not in a
chair on a couch just sort of talking to
the TV you know like it was that
comfortable I think he had a great time
and uh he was very much looking forward
to tonight I'm just hoping Katie can
find her seat when she comes back you
know what I'm saying she couldn't find
her seat at the coronation she had a
seat
I mean we're standing here that's true
we're keeping the seat warm for you
Katie come back thank you sir good to
see you as well
[Music]